we would have
can conclude unanimously on Wednesday evening
in thevermittlungsausschuss,
but we could not,
because one person has chosen it,
torpedo everything.
and this person has a name,
it is Merz who has decided,
not based on constructive cooperation at this point
for companies in Germany,
but 1 game From this whole
to make.
dear Mr. March,
today
they have the chance again,
they stop,
Take companies hostage in Germany
for their own profiling.
it's not worth it.
Mr. March,
they go into them for a moment,
they lay down the false pride that drives them.
today is only 1 time not about them.
it's not about their own ego once and for all.
it's not about that once,
that they are the focus of this story.
listen to the professional advice
their finance ministers,
the CDU,
CSU Minister of Finance in the states.
they have a chance to correct themselves today.
it's about the companies in Germany.
it is about prosperity
of many millions of people in Germany.
dear Mr. March,
let them
the companies and the economy in Germany
not down.